[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
[CLASSICAL MUSIC]
DORINA ARELLANO:
That was so cool.
TINA GUO: Thank you, Dorina.
Thanks for having me here.
DORINA ARELLANO: So awesome.
TINA GUO: Thank you.
DORINA ARELLANO: I just
totally nerded out, so anyway.
So welcome.
Thank you for coming.
TINA GUO: Thank you.
It's lovely to be here.
DORINA ARELLANO:
Do you want to talk
about what you just played?
TINA GUO: Oh, yeah, sure.
So the first piece I
played was very old.
It was by a German
composer named Bach.
He had many, many children.
So he was very prolific in
child making and music writing.
So that was probably one of his
most well-known cello pieces.
You guys probably have heard
it somewhere before, right?
Like Nike commercials
and basically anything
with a cello, it's,
like, synonymous, oh,
that's the cello piece.
And then after that,
it was actually
the main theme from the
new "Wonder Woman" series.
And I did do the original
with Hans Zimmer so.
Thank you.
And it's very exciting
that very soon we're
going to start working
on "Wonder Woman
2," some music for that.
So I'm very excited
about that yes.
DORINA ARELLANO: Awesome.
TINA GUO: And that was it.
Now, I'm sitting here.
DORINA ARELLANO: Cool.
Well, thank you.
Well, I am a huge fan of Tina.
I actually met her a
couple of years ago.
I gave her my business
card, because I
was, like, I need to meet you.
It was really creepy in,
like, a stalkerish way.
So I was, hey, let
me interview you.
TINA GUO: I like stalkers.
DORINA ARELLANO: So
thank you for coming.
I've actually seen
her twice in concert.
She's amazing.
So I wanted to start with
really background questions
like when did you start
playing the cello?
What made you choose that
particular instrument?
Was it kind of like your choice?
Was it forced upon
you by your parents?
What was that?
TINA GUO: Yes.
So I was born in
Shanghai, China.
So I was made in China.
And my first instrument like
many, many Chinese children
was piano.
So I started when I
was three years old.
And then later I
moved to the US.
My parents are actually
both classical musicians.
So they're classical music
teachers who live in San Diego.
And so they popped me out.
And then they came to
the US because they
were able to have an opportunity
to go to school in the US
for music, get a scholarship.
And that was very, very rare
in like post communist China,
like right after.
So they took the opportunity.
And my grandparents,
my mom's parents,
actually raised
me for a few years
while they were here studying.
I got really, really large.
When I came to America--
I'm not kidding you--
I was like 82 pounds
at five years old.
That is not normal.
Right?
So I was a little round
ball, oh, I play the piano.
And then I moved here.
And my parents
thought that I should
play one of the
instruments that they
knew how to play because,
obviously, that would
save money on music lessons.
So I started on the violin.
I was really bad.
I played "Twinkle,
Twinkle Little Star" for--
again, I'm not exaggerating--
like six months.
I could not get past "Twinkle,
Twinkle Little Star."
Like, wow, she's
not talented, right?
So then I switched to the cello.
And for some reason, even though
it's like kind of similar,
it just came a lot
more naturally.
And I seemed to
progress pretty quickly.
So my dad decided, OK, this
is what she's going to play.
And from there on out I was--
I had to say forced
to be honest--
I was forced to practice
eight hours a day, every day--
which I'm grateful for now.
I didn't have much of a
childhood I have to admit.
And I was very angsty.
Hence, probably my
love for metal now.
It was very like,
ah, I hate my life.
I mean it was really extreme.
And I've talked about it
before so hopefully they'll
forgive me for spilling
the family secrets.
But they would lock me in my
room sometimes to practice.
And they'll like let
me out once in a while
to go to the bathroom, maybe
eat something if I was lucky.
But I have to say
that type of like very
regimented, strict training--
really, I have to say it
did pay off in the end,
because if you don't practice
for that many hours every day,
you know, whether it's cello
or swimming or basketball,
you don't build that
type of muscle memory.
So I was more comfortable
playing the cello than really
doing anything else.
So, yeah, to answer
your question,
I was forced into
the family trade,
but I'm happy to be here now.
DORINA ARELLANO:
Yeah, that sounds
like-- your parents
sound both terrifying,
but also thank you
to your parents.
TINA GUO: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No.
They're definitely terrifying.
But also at the same
time, I think it actually
takes a lot of courage and a lot
of determination and sacrifice
on their part, you know?
Because when I have babies--
I don't have kids
yet-- but I don't
know if I can spend
that many hours yelling
at my kids, practice.
DORINA ARELLANO: That's
some dedication for sure.
TINA GUO: Yeah, it's dedication.
DORINA ARELLANO: Yeah.
Cool.
So whether it was growing up or
now, what do you think were--
other than your parents--
music influences
that affected you
or that inspired
you to keep playing,
whether it's this instrument
or other type of music,
because you mentioned
metal as well?
TINA GUO: Yeah, definitely.
So again, growing up because, my
parents are ultra conservative
and just very, very
classical music is good,
anything else is the
music of the devil.
You can't listen to it.
And of course, what
happens when you don't
allow people to do something?
They get very curious.
Especially me,
because I'm really
a contrarian in many ways.
I'm like, oh, yeah?
I'm going to--
DORINA ARELLANO: Same.
TINA GUO: So the very first
exposure that I had to,
I guess, heavier music or
the underground alternative
was a Marilyn Manson.
And how did this come about?
So I was in seventh grade.
This was a little
bit later in life.
I mean that's not that late
in life, but seventh grade.
And I remember I had this
crush on a kid named Luke.
He was like a combination
of a Goth and a nerd.
He was like a nerdy goth?
Right?
He had these really
thick Coke bottle
glasses with thick black rims.
But he also had long hair
down on the shoulders
and black lipstick.
And I'm oh, my god,
who is this kid?
He's so weird.
I love it.
And the neighborhood
we grew up in
was not very
alternative so everybody
was pretty much the
same, very preppy.
DORINA ARELLANO: You're
like the weird one, you.
TINA GUO: Yes, I'm
like he's weird.
I'm going to follow him around
at lunch, like a little loser,
like a stalker, right?
And then so one day, he's
like, hey, Tina, have
you heard of Marilyn Manson?
I'm like who's she?
No, I don't know who that is.
So he let me borrow his
"Antichrist Superstar" CD,
because back in those
days we listened to CDs.
DORINA ARELLANO: Good CD.
TINA GUO: Yeah.
And I had a boombox in my room
that we got at a garage sale
from the next door neighbor,
so nearby garage sale.
And there's a CD
player at the top.
And I remember I would turn
the volume all the way down
to a little bit below
one, so like 0.9 volume
and put my ear up
against the boombox.
I mean, I wouldn't
be here today,
I'd be dead if they heard that.
And I'd be, like,
yeah, I am so cool.
So that actually had
a huge impact on me.
Imagine coming from
classical music to--
I guess that's like industrial--
it's not really metal,
but like heavy
industrial, dark music.
And I was just so--
DORINA ARELLANO: Goth music.
TINA GUO: Goth music.
And I was very fascinated by it.
I started trying to like--
oh, I found a clip.
Sorry.
I'm going to go way
off tangent right now.
Stop me.
OK.
So all these memories
are pouring back.
So I found this clip-on
earring, like just
like the clip on part.
There was no actual earring.
You know the plastic
part, that kind of--
the metal plastic-- you
know what I'm talking about?
Yeah?
I'm like, ah, that would
make a really cool nose ring.
Because I wanted to be cool,
but I didn't have any piercings.
So I would go to school.
I would run into the
bathroom and clip
this plastic clip on earring
thing like a bull, on my nose.
I'm so cool.
So anyway.
So Marilyn Manson.
And then a few years later in
high school, my best friend--
her name is also Tina--
and she had a Guns
and Roses tape.
Oh, my gosh, a cassette tape.
"Appetite for Destruction."
So I heard that.
And then the third musical
influence that I heard,
but I only heard the first
two tracks of their album
was a Daft Punk CD that I got
at yet another garage sale.
But it was scratched up.
So only the first-- it
wasn't even first two tracks.
The first track
and a half worked.
And so I would like listen
to it for a track and a half.
And then it would skip
and then stop working.
I'd rewind it and just
keep listening to it.
And that was my
musical influence, that
and classical music.
DORINA ARELLANO: That's so good.
And that actually makes sense.
If you follow Tina's
career, it makes sense,
because she's really all
over the place in a good way.
You know, she's not
the typical cellist
that you would go see at
the Disney Concert Hall.
She does all of this cool stuff.
One of the concerts
that I saw her at she
ended up playing "Super
Mario Bros," the theme.
And then all of a sudden
went into a heavy metal
version of it.
And I freaked out, because
I was like it's like she's
dedicating this to me.
It was so cool.
TINA GUO: It was for
you, just for you.
DORINA ARELLANO: Yes.
Thank you.
That's right.
And it was really cool.
So she has albums out, right?
There's this one
called "Game On"
where you play video game music.
So how did that come about?
And how do you, as a musician--
because do you do your own
compositions and arrangements
for when you're doing
a cover and putting
your own spin on it?
Like how does that blend of
metal and classical come about?
TINA GUO: Right, right.
So this album that
she's talking about,
it was actually my first album.
I finally got signed
to a major label,
to Sony, almost two years ago.
So "Game On" was the first
label released album that I did.
But actually,
previous to that, I
self-released nine
albums by myself.
So I self-funded it.
I recorded it myself, didn't
know what I was doing,
but I figured it
out along the way.
If you listened to
my oldest albums,
it's like, whoa,
that's really bad.
And it hopefully gets
a little bit better
as I'm figuring out what to do.
But I released albums
that were fully classical.
And my parents were
happy about that.
And then I did some
super metal ones.
There is one called
"Cello Metal,"
because that's how creative
I am-- cello, metal.
And then so when I
got signed to Sony,
it was weird timing
because I had planned
on doing a music video--
music video, sorry--
a game music album.
And since I moved to LA,
I feel like everyone's
in the entertainment industry
in some way or another.
So I started doing-- when I
came to college, as a side
gig to make money,
amongst other things,
I tried to sell Avon, et cetera.
I wasn't very good at that.
But I started
doing session work.
And slowly I built that up.
And I ended up playing
on a lot of video game,
like in the actual soundtracks.
So I had thought,
oh, maybe I should
do some versions of
my own of the stuff
that I've played on or some
of my favorite game music.
And so when Sony signed
me, they said, oh, we
were thinking that maybe you
could do a video game music
album.
Like no way, check
out my spreadsheet--
because I love Google
Spreadsheets-- so I already
had a spreadsheet of all
the music I wanted to do,
the tracks.
And so it was really
one of those situations
where it was perfect,
perfect timing.
And so I just kind of picked
some of my favorite music, some
of the games that I
did play a little bit
and then some just
epic music that I
love like "Final Fantasy 7."
I mean it's just
like opulent music.
So that's how it
kind of came about.
DORINA ARELLANO: So cool.
Do you have a
favorite video game?
TINA GUO: It doesn't count--
I don't know if it
counts as a video game.
But what I'm playing right
now-- which is really bad.
I don't know if you guys play
"Homescapes" or "Gardenscapes?"
No.
It's like what's that?
My mom plays it, too.
That's when you know it's bad.
I was telling my mom, oh,
I have found this thing,
like "Gardenscapes."
What?
Me, too.
I play "Gardenscapes."
I'm oh, no, I'm like playing
the same games as my mom.
It's kind of like
little matching games.
And then you can win points
and upgrade your garden.
I know.
Not metal.
DORINA ARELLANO:
I would play it.
I mean, probably.
TINA GUO: It's on iPad
and your iPhone and stuff.
DORINA ARELLANO: There you go.
Now, we have to check it out.
TINA GUO: OK.
Promoting "Gardenscapes."
DORINA ARELLANO: So, yeah.
You mentioned your
album "Cello Metal."
And I mean you have the songs
by Black Sabbath and Metallica,
Slayer, it's so good.
These are not just
covers, right?
Like there's arrangements
that go into this.
Did you end up really
getting into metal?
And then it seems like
sometimes-- correct me
if I'm wrong-- but
like when you're
playing the metal
versions of songs,
you kind of treat the
cello like a guitar.
TINA GUO: Yeah,
exactly, exactly.
So when I was listening
to that Guns N' Roses
"Appetite for Destruction,"
you know, Slash.
I was, like, oh, my
god, I want to be Slash.
How do I become Slash?
So I think, basically, what I
did with the electric cello is
just try to experiment with it.
I use guitar effects.
This is a pedal born
meant for a guitar player.
But I thought it's close enough,
it's kind of in the same range.
And so, yeah, that's
exactly what I try to do.
And even with the "Wonder
Woman" main theme,
I sometimes I
would go on YouTube
and look at-- the people
just upload the track.
And there's some comments
like, oh, the guitar is cool.
I'm like, it's not a
guitar, it's cello.
But at the same time, it's
good, because I want it
to sound like a guitar player.
So the fact that it's
a little bit confusing
is like both a good and
a bad thing, you know?
DORINA ARELLANO: No.
And that's true.
That's actually--
because I'm a nerd--
I've also corrected people,
because they'll be like,
oh, yeah, I love that little
guitar solo in "Wonder Woman."
And I'm, like, that is a cello.
What are you talking about?
So speaking of
"Wonder Woman," that
must be such a cool experience.
Tell us about that.
What was it like to
get involved-- first
of all with one of my favorite
composers of all time, which
is Hans Zimmer and
then Junkie XL,
that they made this
really cool iconic theme?
What was it like?
And how did that
process come about
to be involved in
such an iconic movie?
TINA GUO: Right.
So I think to backtrack, the
way that I met Hans was actually
through YouTube.
So my very, very first
music video, I released it--
my gosh-- like 10
years ago, I think.
Yeah.
I'm old.
No, I'm not that old.
But 10 years ago, it's
called "Queen Bee"
and it was my metal version
of "Flight of the Bumblebee."
I know it's been done before.
But I was just starting,
I wasn't very original.
But anyway, so I
did a metal cover.
And he actually saw
the music video,
because he spends a lot of time
watching YouTube videos looking
at musicians.
And his office
actually contacted me.
And at the time, I was trying
to become a metal cellist.
My life goal was to
play with Rammstein.
And that's what--
and I thought, oh,
if I release this
music video, maybe
metal bands will see the video.
And they'll be like, oh, she
should like come play with us.
So that was my entire purpose.
But instead, that somehow
accidentally segued me
into a career in
soundtrack work.
So now the majority
of my work here in LA,
I work on movie scores, TV
scores, video game stuff.
And so he saw the
video, called me.
The first movie that
we worked on together
was "Sherlock Holmes."
The very first one.
I remember I walked in--
so bad.
If he watches this, please
don't get offended Hans.
Sorry-- I actually
don't know who he was.
So when his assistant
called, like, I'm
calling from Hans Zimmer's
office, I'm like who?
What?
So I went in.
I still didn't know
what I was expecting
to his office in Santa Monica.
And they're, like, oh,
Hans is having lunch
in the next building, because
there's all these buildings.
So I went up there.
And I did recognize Guy Ritchie.
They were having lunch.
And so I sat down.
And there's like
all these, you know,
cool celebrity people
and then, like, me.
I'm like, oh, wow, OK.
I guess I'm in a good situation.
And so that's how we
started working together.
And then we worked
on a bunch of--
"Inception" and a lot
of movies after that.
And so this one, I
think they had actually
been experimenting.
Originally, they were
thinking it would be a vocal,
like a female vocal.
And for some reason--
they tried different singers--
like it just wasn't
quite fitting.
And the Hans said, oh, we
should have Tina come in
with her electric cello
and do some weird shrieking
sound, like a screaming Amazon.
And so I went in.
And it's a pretty-- it's a
simple melody that repeats over
and over and over.
I literally played
it at least 1,000
times over and over and over.
But we finally figured it out.
And the theme is
actually layered.
It's not just one
electric cello,
but it's like 30 layers
of electric cello
to get that really fat sound.
DORINA ARELLANO:
And that's all you.
TINA GUO: Yes, it's all me.
So, yeah, lots of
multi tracking.
And actually Junkie, I've
never even met him in person.
He wasn't actually there.
So it's just myself and Hans
and then all of Hans' peoples,
entourage--
yeah, yeah, yeah.
DORINA ARELLANO: But they both
composed the theme, right?
TINA GUO: I believe so, yeah.
A lot of times,
there's so many people
working on different
components of it.
But, yeah, definitely.
DORINA ARELLANO: That's so cool.
I mean, I remember the first
time I heard that theme was--
I think it was "Batman
v. Superman the Movie."
TINA GUO: Yes.
DORINA ARELLANO: And
there's that scene where--
spoilers-- Wonder
Woman basically
saves Batman, because
she actually has powers.
No offense to Batman.
I love Batman, too.
But she basically does this
and the music comes on.
And I hear the cello.
And I'm like, oh, my god,
like this is like my jam.
I was so happy about it.
That's so cool.
TINA GUO: Yea.
DORINA ARELLANO: And
speaking of Hans, that's
actually one of the best
concerts I've been to.
And I go to like
30 concerts a year.
It's bad.
And Tina was there along with
all these other great studio
musicians that Hans brought.
And they basically
just play his scores.
And that was such
a cool concert.
I mean they played
everything from "Inception"
to "Sherlock Holmes."
Obviously, you
played "Wonder Woman"
and "Pirates of the Caribbean."
What was that like?
And was that kind of
like a dream of you
to be on stage with the
best musicians in the world?
And what's that
compared to what you
want to do in the future
or dreams of yours?
TINA GUO: Right, right.
So of course, it was.
I don't know if you
guys have seen it.
It's on Netflix like
the "Live in Prague,"
our show that we did in Prague.
This was two tours
ago, two years ago.
But when Hans first
said, oh, we're
thinking of maybe
taking this on the road
instead of being locked
up in a dark room all day
writing music.
And I thought, great, because
for me, I love studio music.
But while I'm still young enough
to prance around on stage,
I want to take the opportunity
to travel, to perform live.
And so it was really,
really amazing.
And we played mostly
arenas, which is crazy.
Because we all thought
is anyone going to come?
Is it going to be five people?
But it was amazing, because,
I mean, Hans is huge.
So all over the world
the arenas were full.
So it was an amazing experience.
And prior to that, I
actually, in a past life,
I was in the Cirque du Soleil.
And so it was weird to kind
of revisit the same arenas
that we played, but
with Hans this time.
And it was just, yeah,
I mean what can I say?
It's really, really,
really awesome.
And there was good food.
DORINA ARELLANO: Oh,
that's always good.
TINA GUO: I like free catering.
DORINA ARELLANO: Wait.
So you were in Cirque du Soleil?
What did you do?
TINA GUO: Yeah.
Well, I play the cello.
I was kind of like
this weird cello--
DORINA ARELLANO: Oh, I thought
you were like an acrobat,
and I was, like, ooh.
TINA GUO: I'm not that flexible.
No.
I was like a weird cello alien.
And I was wearing this outfit.
I was skinnier then.
I mean I know I'm not large
now, but they put me on a diet.
They're like no.
I was the largest person
in the entire show.
Like all these like acrobat
girls with eight packs.
I'm like Jesus Christ.
So I would actually paint on
fake abs to try to blend in.
And I remember one
time, someone I
think waiting for us
outside of the stage door.
And they saw me.
He's, like, oh, you're that
cellist, man, you are cut.
I'm like, it's makeup.
Because from far away, if you
have really bad makeup on,
it actually looks like
you're super buff.
And I have a one
pack of nothing.
You know?
And the acrobats
are looking at me,
they're like
working out all day.
And I'm just eating in catering.
And I paint on my abs.
But, yeah, I was
wearing this outfit.
It was all Swarovski crystal.
And it was the "Michael
Jackson, the Immortal Tour
by Cirque Du Soleil."
So it was actually half
owned by the Jackson estate.
So this was after
Michael passed.
Obviously, he
couldn't do the tour.
So we had his vocals.
And then it was combined
with a Cirque du Soleil
to add in other elements.
And now they have the Michael
Jackson show in Las Vegas.
That's kind of like
the smaller version.
But the original one that
opened was also an arena tour.
So, yeah, I did
that for two years.
I was a gypsy.
DORINA ARELLANO: That's crazy.
You've done everything.
And you're so young and
you've done everything.
Good for you.
So you have a new album
coming out this year,
or you're working
on this year, right?
TINA GUO: Hopefully, it
will come out this year.
We're working on
song number two.
So we'll see how it progresses.
DORINA ARELLANO:
Can you tell us--
can you give us a little
bit of a preview for it
or what you're working on?
TINA GUO: Yeah.
Like I was telling
you, Dorina, earlier,
the idea for this
album has already
changed like five times.
But that's part of
the creative process.
You think you have a great
idea, then you do it.
And you're like, wow,
this is really horrible.
And then you erase it
and you start again.
So I think we have the
general theme down.
It's not really-- I mean, it's
kind of a cover, but not really
a cover, because I wanted
to do original material.
But being that I don't sing
and it's instrumental music,
it is difficult to have
something to grasp.
It's not radio friendly.
So we thought, what if we took
some classical pieces, but not
an entire cover, where you
just take a short segment.
Like rappers, they sample
stuff that's recognizable,
and then kind of expand that,
and explode that into something
original and different.
So that's what we're working on.
So I guess you would
call it like classically
based, cinematic medley.
Of course, there will
be some metal elements.
DORINA ARELLANO: Yea.
TINA GUO: Yea.
Just for you.
And, yeah, that's
what we're working on.
I'm hoping it will come out
around the same time as "Wonder
Woman 2."
That's our whole
goal for the timing.
DORINA ARELLANO: Cool.
Can you tell us anything about
the "Wonder Woman" music or no?
No, spoilers.
TINA GUO: No, sorry.
DORINA ARELLANO:
Contracts, I know.
I got it.
OK.
So I wanted to ask about
since you perform with Hans,
are there collaborators
that you work
with that it was a very
meaningful thing to you
or is there somebody
that you dream
of working with in the
future that you're like,
oh, I would die if I
worked with that person?
TINA GUO: Yes.
So remember how I said
that that first music
video that I made and I
spent every penny that I
had on at the time and I was
broke after, this metal music
video?
I was hoping that
Rammstein would see it.
I still really would
love to work with them.
My thing is I don't want to--
I never reach out to
people and say, hey,
I want to work with you, because
I try to wait and manifest it.
And hopefully, eventually,
somehow it'll just come
or we'll have mutual friends
or something weird will happen.
So my dream is
that one day, I'll
be able to play with Rammstein.
Hello, Rammstein.
DORINA ARELLANO: Well,
we'll send this to him.
TINA GUO: OK.
DORINA ARELLANO: And then, you
were just at Noam recently.
TINA GUO: Yes.
DORINA ARELLANO:
And for those of you
that don't know, if you
could explain what that is.
But Tina actually has
an instrument line,
because she does everything.
So can you talk a little
bit about that as well?
TINA GUO: Oh, yes.
So in addition to
music, I'm actually
very passionate about
entrepreneurship and investing.
But that's a whole other thing
that we won't go into today.
But one of my, I
guess, side businesses
is a line of instruments,
bows, and pickups
for acoustic string instruments.
So I have a couple of different
cello models, classical cello
models.
We offer bows in both wood and
carbon fiber in custom colors.
You can even get
like the hair here.
This is actually horse hair.
But don't worry, no horses
were harmed in the making
of any of these bows.
And we dye them all kind
of different colors.
And so that's just something
that I also do on the side.
DORINA ARELLANO: What's the
difference between horse hair
and other types of hair
that are used for bows?
TINA GUO: So on the bows that I
play with the electric cello--
I actually tried not
to go too crazy today
because it's noon, Monday--
so I don't want to be too extra.
But if I play really, really
hard and I use a normal bow,
I'll literally destroy like one
bow every 15 minutes, maybe.
Because if you hit it really
hard, all the hairs will break.
And so for actually that
cello when I play it,
I usually use fishing wire,
because it's like plastic.
So it doesn't sound as good,
but it lasts a lot longer.
Again, since it costs about $80,
usually about $80 per rehair.
But for the
classical cello, I do
use the traditional
horsehair on the bows.
DORINA ARELLANO: And I want
to talk about the difference
between when--
because, I actually grew up
playing the cello, this one.
How did you transition
to doing electric?
And what are the challenges
or what are the differences
or what's better or worse
between both instruments?
TINA GUO: Right, right.
I always tell people
if you compare it
to a classical guitar
and an electric guitar,
it's exactly the same.
So, yeah, I mean the frets
are in the same place.
But as far as, obviously, when
I play this cello, I'm sitting.
And when I play
that, it's standing.
And it's actually more difficult
to play the electric cello
in tune, because your whole
body-- as you can see,
it's just one end pin.
So it's kind of like
a tripod situation
where my legs are
like this, right?
And you're kind of
trying to move with it
so it doesn't fall over.
Because when I started,
it took me about two years
to figure out how to play it
without looking super awkward.
I'm sure I still look awkward.
There's a lot of people
who play electric violin.
There's some people who
play electric cello.
But it's still not a super
popular thing, I guess.
So I was really trying to
figure out how to do it
and to be able to
stand so you can
be a little bit more mobile
instead of just sitting
all the time.
DORINA ARELLANO: Yeah,
because if you're
trying to hit the right
notes and you're playing
and you're moving around, how
do you hit the right notes?
TINA GUO: Right, right, right.
And there's no frets.
It's muscle memory.
So genuinely, it took
me like two years
of non-stop practice on that
one just to not sound horrible.
Yeah.
DORINA ARELLANO:
That's so awesome.
And so I mentioned, I
grew up playing the cello.
I haven't played in years.
So for somebody like me--
TINA GUO: Do you want to play?
DORINA ARELLANO: No.
TINA GUO: OK.
DORINA ARELLANO: Definitely not.
Especially after she played.
So for somebody
like me or somebody
that's a beginner
that's hoping to play--
like for me it seems very
daunting to get back into this.
Just because as you mentioned
earlier, it takes discipline.
What advice would
you give people
like me and beginner musicians?
Or what tips or what do you do
to not get uninspired and keep
playing?
TINA GUO: Right.
I think everything's
just about consistency.
And I'm not going to
lie and say, you know,
you're always going
to want to practice.
I don't even want to
practice sometimes.
But I have the internal
Asian tiger parent already
in my brain.
So even if I don't want
to, I'm like I have to.
I have to.
So if you just force
yourself to be consistent.
And I'm not saying eight hours a
day, because we all have lives.
And I don't do eight
hours a day anymore.
But even if it's a good 30
minutes, like a really focused
30 minutes every day or
an hour, whether you're
learning cello or anything else,
it does come pretty quickly.
But it's mostly
about consistency.
Yeah.
DORINA ARELLANO: OK.
We'll see.
But thank you.
TINA GUO: OK.
Sure.
DORINA ARELLANO:
So we actually only
have time for one more
question, unfortunately.
And then Tina is going
to perform one more song.
And then think of
some good questions,
because we'll open up the
floor to audience questions.
So I wanted to also
ask about you've
had a lot of
partnerships with brands.
And that's interesting
for a musician.
Can you tell us about that?
I think you worked
with Bentley last year.
You're working
with Ritz-Carlton.
What's that like?
And how do those things happen?
That's so cool.
TINA GUO: Right.
Thank you.
Definitely very
grateful for that.
And again, I don't reach
out usually-- not usually,
I never--
I don't reach out to brands.
I don't have someone
pursuing it for me.
So these happened
organically, which
I think is the best way
for things to happen.
And so the Bentley partnership,
actually the Marketing Director
Mike Sayer of Bentley in the
UK, he came to one of my shows.
And then for some reason,
he Instagram messaged me.
But you know on Instagram
if you don't follow them,
it goes to your
archive messages.
So I didn't see his
messages for months.
Right?
And I think finally
he'll emailed me.
And he's like, oh, I
tried to message you,
but you ignored me.
I'm messaging--
DORINA ARELLANO: He
stalked you the wrong way.
He should have given you a
business card like I did.
TINA GUO: Exactly.
No, he came to the show, but
then he didn't come in person,
you know.
He didn't leave a
card like she did.
So anyway, we connected.
And then last year, I did
four performances for Bentley.
I actually wrote the music.
I scored a commercial for them
for the new Bentayga Hybrid,
which is their SUV,
hybrid SUV, which
works with the idea of
taking something old--
Bentley is turning 100
years old this year,
so it's a very old company--
so taking something that's
old like this cello,
made in 1880 in Paris, France,
and transforming it and making
it something modern,
electric, with a hybrid SUV.
So we did that.
And that was a great
partnership for a year.
And then this year I am a brand
partner with the Ritz-Carlton.
So I'll be visiting some
of their different resorts.
I know, awful job
visiting the resorts
and getting inspired by the
locations, the experiences,
the food that we'll have
there and taking that
and composing a kind of a
soundtrack, a theme song,
for each location.
And then playing a little bit,
playing like a very short show
at each one.
So I don't know.
I'm super excited about it.
We have a meeting
on Wednesday to plan
the schedule for this year.
DORINA ARELLANO: Cool, man.
That sounds like a
nice part of the job.
TINA GUO: Yeah,
yeah, definitely.
I love to travel.
I love to eat.
I love to play music.
Oh, and my fiance Rambo
gets to come, too.
DORINA ARELLANO: Yeah.
TINA GUO: Yeah.
Yea.
Hopefully he doesn't get
in trouble at work, though.
He's supposed to be
at work right now.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
TINA GUO: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So first of all,
thanks for coming out.
And thanks for having us.
TINA GUO: Oh, of
course, thank you.
AUDIENCE: That was wonderful.
TINA GUO: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I saw you're
playing not just the cello,
but also the erhu?
TINA GUO: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And I
was just wondering
if you had some thoughts
like how they compare
and contrast, the spirit
of the instrument.
TINA GUO: Right.
So the erhu was that the
tall, thin Chinese thing.
And it's made out of
rosewood and snakeskin.
And I don't really know--
there's a fingerboard, so it's
kind of similar to a cello.
But the strings are actually
suspended in the air.
I wish I brought one
to show you guys.
So you're not actually
pressing against anything,
so it's just a string.
And it's-- I don't know.
I don't even know if
I play it properly.
I'm self-taught.
So I bought one.
Actually-- wait.
Do we have time if I tell a
really quick story about how
I learned to play the erhu?
DORINA ARELLANO: Yes.
TINA GUO: I was doing this
concert with the Golden State
Pops Orchestra and they were
doing a video game music
concert.
And I was already playing--
I don't know if you
guys play "Journey."
No?
Yeah.
So, yeah, Austin Wintory.
So I did the original--
I play the cello
solos for that game.
And so we were
playing "Journey."
It's, like, oh, Tina, since
you're playing in the concert,
you're going to be there
already, and you're Chinese,
do you play the Chinese erhu?
You know, because all
Chinese people play the erhu.
But I thought, oh,
like what is it?
They're, like, yeah.
We have this game and
it features the erhu.
And I thought, wow,
another opportunity
to be featured on stage?
Yeah, I want to do that.
I could wear something Chinese.
It will be really fun.
But I had never played
the erhu before.
So I lied.
I said, yeah, I
could play the erhu.
Just if you could just send
me the music ahead of time--
and there was still
like two weeks
till the concert, which
is not that much time.
And so I got off the
phone, got on Craigslist.
I was searching erhu, erhu.
There was no erhus for sale.
So I finally found
a store in Texas,
in Austin, Texas, that had
erhus with overnight shipping.
So I paid like $100
extra for shipping.
It arrived.
I practiced every night.
I didn't sleep.
I was trying to learn.
I was watching YouTube videos
like how to play the erhu.
And I think I kind of did OK.
We used a lot of
reverb in the concert.
And it was pretty simple.
It wasn't a super
complicated part, thankfully.
So that's how I play the erhu.
So when you ask
me about the erhu,
I really am not
educated on actually
what it's supposed
to sound like.
It sounds very ethnic, I
guess, because the tonality
is different.
AUDIENCE: But it's
still continuous pitch
and everything.
So I guess you had
faith in yourself,
because you knew the principles.
TINA GUO: Yes, the principles.
And you just kind
of slide around.
If you miss it, it's
like I meant to do that.
It's part of the
Chineseness of it.
You know?
It's like
[SLIDING NOTES],, right?
And it is very
forgiving in that way.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thanks a lot.
DORINA ARELLANO: Next question?
AUDIENCE: Do you
have anything else
you can say about working
on "Journey" with Austin?
Like what you think about
having such evocative
visuals to go with your music
and those kinds of things.
TINA GUO: Yeah.
So when we started
working on "Journey,"
I mean it was many years ago.
I met Austin through
USC at school.
And we had no idea it
was going to turn out
to be such a success.
It was the first video
game ever nominated
for Best Soundtrack
for a Grammy.
But when we did it, he was
still in his old studio, which
literally was just like a room.
And we were both
just slumming it,
like trying to figure
out what to do.
And we both had no idea
that it would turn out
to be such a big,
successful game.
And, yeah, I remember I just
went to a studio a few times.
We would try out different
Ideas, again, lots of reverb.
And I saw some of
the early visuals,
but it was much later
that it was actually
placed into the game.
So, yeah, it was fun.
It was great.
And I still work with
Austin, so it's good.
Yeah.
He just wrote to me
Instagram messaged me right
before I got up here.
AUDIENCE: You don't have
him blocked, fortunately.
TINA GUO: I don't what?
AUDIENCE: You don't
have him blocked.
TINA GUO: I don't
have him blocked?
No.
DORINA ARELLANO: Who's next.
Over here?
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
The effects of the "Wonder
Woman" soundtrack--
I mean I love that song--
TINA GUO: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: --made me
think a little bit
of Les Claypool or Tom Reelo.
I'm curious what
it's like to learn
the classical style
versus kind of try
to push the envelope of what
an instrument is capable of.
Is there any overlap with
some of those artists
or are you just out
there on your own?
TINA GUO: Yeah, definitely.
I mean when I started, again,
YouTube was my teacher.
So when I first got
my electric cello,
I think it was about 11 years
ago when I was in college.
I bought an electric cello
with a credit card from Yamaha.
And then I was, like, OK,
what do I do with this?
So I would just go on YouTube
and watch guitar tutorials
and try to like-- because
the tonality again
is very, very different
from a classical instrument.
And then also being able to
improvise, because most of us
classical musicians are
not taught to improvise.
You play exactly what
you're told to play.
And you play it the same
way every time, right?
So it was more of a mental thing
even rather than a physical.
Because once you
wrap your head around
you can do whatever
you want, you
can express yourself
through the music,
and then just learning some
different scalar patterns
and passages that you can
use in your solos or whatnot.
And then just playing
around with pedals.
I actually went full
digital very, very recently.
This is from Line 6.
But I was like a big
collector of pedals,
so like analog pedals.
And I used to love those.
But after a while there's
some feedback issues
you know and now
with new technology.
This unit right here,
it's both an amp modeler.
So instead of having a giant
amplifier being carried
in here, everything
is processed through
this little pedal board.
So all the effects, all this amp
sounds, everything is in there.
So it's really,
really convenient.
DORINA ARELLANO:
Going off of that,
is that basically your
like piece of equipment
you can't live without?
Or do you have something
that you really, really love
that you take
everywhere with you?
TINA GUO: This is it now.
Before when I did
shows, oh, my gosh,
I had to hire a company because
these amps are so heavy.
And of course, I like to
be melodramatic and have
lots of different amps.
So they come in like with a
big truck, unload everything,
and then all my pedals
and this and that.
And now this little
thing on the floor,
you just put it in a backpack.
I don't carry it, my
fiance Rambo carries it,
but still, it's easier.
It's easier-- it's
easier for him.
And he likes it, too, right?
RAMBO: Yes.
TINA GUO: OK.
DORINA ARELLANO: Good answer.
Next question?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks very much for coming.
Your music is amazing.
TINA GUO: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: What you're
talking about with what
you've been doing with
the electric cello reminds
me a lot of--
have you ever heard
of Ronald Jenkees?
He's a keyboardist.
I've seen some of his
videos on YouTube.
But he has this one song
that's called "Guitar Sounds"
that he's using a keyboard.
I actually thought
the first time
I heard it that it was just
entirely electric guitar.
And I was so surprised when I
learned that it was actually
a keyboard.
So it might be something
interesting for you
to look into because
he's doing something
similar except with
a keyboard that you
do with the electric cello.
TINA GUO: Yeah, definitely.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
it's really cool.
Ronald Jenkees.
TINA GUO: Got it.
Thank you.
DORINA ARELLANO: Maybe
you can play with him
and Rammstein one day.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That would be really cool.
Concerts.
TINA GUO: No.
Rammstein's mine.
I'm not sharing.
AUDIENCE: That'd be an
amazing concert opportunity.
But you don't reach out to him.
So he would have to find you.
TINA GUO: No.
I check other artists
out and stuff.
But it's usually for
people that, you know--
I don't know what it is, I
just feel like energetically--
is that wrong?
Should I be--
I just don't want to
be one of those people,
oh, work with me please,
I'll play cello for you.
DORINA ARELLANO:
There's a balance.
TINA GUO: There's a balance.
It's more of
dangling the carrot.
DORINA ARELLANO: I think
you could reach out
to Rammstein is all I'm saying.
TINA GUO: Yeah.
But I'd be so embarrassed
and heartbroken if they said,
no, thank you.
Nein.
DORINA ARELLANO: But
then, they're not cool.
TINA GUO: OK.
DORINA ARELLANO: So it's fine.
TINA GUO: I'll give it
five more years and then--
DORINA ARELLANO: Next question?
AUDIENCE: So speaking
of metal, what
are you listening to recently?
TINA GUO: Not a lot of metal
recently, I have to be honest.
So recently, I've been obsessed
with financial YouTube videos.
I have them on a playlist and
I listen to them every morning
if I'm putting on makeup.
But as far as like metal,
obviously Rammstein
is my big obsession obsession.
And I'm into-- like when
you mentioned earlier about
my "Cello Metal" album-- more of
the classic, old school metal.
Like now, honestly, I haven't
heard a lot of new, new bands
that I'm really, really into.
Huh?
AUDIENCE: Whitechapel.
TINA GUO: Yeah.
Whitechapel's cool, you know.
But old school
stuff, Black Sabbath,
Metallica, and whatnot, but
more industrial metal for sure.
Yeah.
DORINA ARELLANO: It'd be so
cool if you played with--
there's these newer bands.
I don't know if you were
thinking about these,
but like Behemoth and Sleep.
Like there's just more newer
bands that I think would love--
I'm going to hook you
guys up with them.
TINA GUO: OK.
DORINA ARELLANO: Yeah, yeah.
It's going to happen.
Next?
AUDIENCE: Hey.
TINA GUO: Hello.
AUDIENCE: So I'm a
pianist and a huge gamer.
And I remember reading
on the bio intro
that you also worked
with "League of Legends."
I'm kind of curious
how that went.
TINA GUO: Oh, yeah.
So I play-- oh, my gosh,
I forgot what year it was.
I think it was three
championships ago when it was
in LA at the Staples Center.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TINA GUO: Do you remember?
I think it was a few years ago.
They just reached out
and said would you want
to play for the championship?
So we opened it.
It was myself, Wes
Borland from Limp Bizkit,
and then the drummer
from Combichrist
who just left the band,
and then Crystal Method,
and an orchestra.
So it was like this big--
like, not a mess-- so it was an
organized mess of just stuff.
And, yeah, it was a lot of fun.
And my brother was
really-- my little brother.
He's a huge "League of Legends"
player, him and his wife.
So they were
totally geeking out.
And I remember they
gave us a gift bag.
And there was this stuffed
animal thing from--
and then they're like,
oh, my god, can I have it?
I'm like sure you can have it.
So they were happy about it.
I think they were more excited
than I was to be honest.
DORINA ARELLANO: You
also have a "God of War"
music video coming out, right?
TINA GUO: Actually, yeah.
It came out, I
believe, last month.
So, yeah, I did a
cover of "God of War."
I try to play the game,
I'm not very good at it.
DORINA ARELLANO: It's hard.
It's good, but it's hard.
TINA GUO: It's really hard.
Oh, my goodness.
But yes, the video is
out on YouTube now.
DORINA ARELLANO:
It's really cool.
You guys check it out.
TINA GUO: Thank you.
DORINA ARELLANO: Time
for one more question?
TINA GUO: It smells
good in here.
DORINA ARELLANO: Yeah.
Is that curry?
Is that it?
Are we good?
OK.
TINA GUO: Thank you, guys.
DORINA ARELLANO: Well,
you guys, can you
tell people where they can
find you on the Internets?
TINA GUO: Yeah, so
Tina Guo, G-U-O--
if you just got to tinaguo.com,
that is my website.
And there's links to everything.
I'm on the usual Facebook,
Instagram, Twitter, YouTube.
I don't need to tell
you guys, you guys know.
If you just Google it,
you can write to me.
DORINA ARELLANO: Oh, Google her.
TINA GUO: Right.
DORINA ARELLANO: But thank
you so much for coming.
That was so awesome.
Thank you.
TINA GUO: Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]